je crois qu'il faut être clair c'est
fini le temps où les ministères
travailler en silo chacun dans son coin
sans se préoccuper de ce qui se passe
ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya un travail en commun
et c'est dommage que vous aussi pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas ensemble a coûté moi je
moi je suis là écoutez moi je suis là et
moi je fais mon boulot en étant là parce
que je suis une mise de l'agriculture et
que ma présence c'est le travail qui est
le mien c'est d'être ici pendant huit
jours après mes collègues il faut ce
qu'ils veulent
moi j'ai grand plaisir à les accueillir
demain j'accueille le premier ministre
j'accueille le ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec qui nous faisons beaucoup
de travaux interrogé mois sur abc avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
interrogé moins sur ce que nous allons
faire avec la ministre d outre-mer
interrogés - sur ce que nous allons
faire avec la ministre de l'enseignement
de robert d'aborder d'autres sujets dont
à tout ça parce qu'il ya tellement faire
les choses maintenant mes collègues sont
libres de faire ce qu'ils veulent ce
n'est pas moi qui gère l'emploi du temps
et les agendas droit jallet champ libre
en fête vous avez champ libre si le
salon de l'agriculture s'est ouvert sur
le monde c'est ouvert à tout le monde et
moi je suis très heureux d'accueillir
tous les gens qui viennent ici très bien
y compris n'est que la hulot s'il
finissait par se décider au notamment un
sondage